un vistazo a la movilidad del futuro
corea del sur realizó una exhibición de
lo que será su sistema de control
vehicular de movilidad aérea urbana un
piloto el modelo de dos pasajeros
fabricados por la alemana voló cop ter
impulsado por rotores similares a los de
un helicóptero para despegues y
aterrizajes verticales el aparato puede
ser pilotado con o sin intervención
humana
nuestros motores y rotores tenemos 18 de
ellos así que si perdimos uno o dos no
importa y tenemos toda esta redundancia
en nuestro sistema completo y esto
proporciona seguridad para el pasajero
es provide safety photo caster desde el
año pasado corea del sur anunció un plan
para iniciar el transporte aéreo urbano
comercial en 2025 el ministerio de
transporte calcula que estos servicios
podrán hacer el tránsito más expedito el
tiempo de viaje de estas aeronaves puede
durar una tercera parte del traslado por
tierra
se espera que la escala económica sea de
entre 700 y mil 700 billones de wones
creo que tendría un efecto económico de
más de 60 billones de wones teniendo en
cuenta el producto interno bruto de
corea del sur área de moneda y éxito
con esta apuesta según le espera ser
pionero en transformar la movilidad de
tierra a aire así como impulsar una
nueva economía basada en vehículos
eléctricos